it is quiet in Washington this weekend
with both Congress and President Trump
still out of town for the holiday when
the Senate returns in January one of the
first orders of business will be the
impeachment trial of President Trump
chip Reid is traveling with the
president in Florida right now a chip so
where does the impeachment trial stand
right now
well the impeachment process is in limbo
right now the house did impeach the
president on two counts before they went
home for the holidays but Nancy Pelosi
the Speaker of the House has not yet
sent those articles of impeachment over
to the Senate what's the holdup well
Pelosi says she wants to make sure the
trial is fair which appears to mean that
Democrats will be able to call witnesses
they want to hear from White House
acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney and
former national security advisor John
Bolton among others the White House is
expected to oppose that vigorously as it
did in the house and chip what's the
latest response from Republicans well
the president in particular has been
tweeting angrily all week most of it
aimed at Nancy Pelosi in one tweet he
said so interesting to see Nancy Pelosi
demanding fairness from Senate Majority
Leader McConnell when she presided over
the most unfair hearing in the history
of the United States Congress in the
Senate the president's party will be in
control and Senator McConnell says he'll
be closely coordinating with the White
House counsel's office now at least four
Republicans would have to join the
Democrats in voting in favor of
witnesses but keep in mind even if that
does happen
that does not mean those Republicans are
going to join the Democrats and join the
Democrats in voting to remove the
president from office and it takes a
two-thirds supermajority to remove a
president from office under the
Constitution and that in this case is
very unlikely
besides impeachment that obviously has
been the big headline but some other
issues that are facing the
administration North Korea there was the
promised Christmas gift but it seemed
pretty quiet on that front this week it
did but keep in mind that intelligence
experts have said that even though North
Korea called it a Christmas gift
intelligence experts say it's more
likely to happen after the first of the
year so they are still very closely
monitoring that situation what they fear
most of
is that it could be a test of an
intercontinental ballistic missile and
if that does happen it would be a major
setback for the president's efforts to
denuclearize North Korea all right chip
thank you very much
you